no I Fronteras remoras Jeff Raymond
Ellen Haney Oh el talento in Karachi on
Dakara Pais dakara continental el mundo
historias que nos como en esta noche
celebramos lifestyle India la
importancia de la cultura in el idioma
the different the spices
[Applause]
members of the movie Academy come from
across the globe so it is truly fitting
that this year foreign language films
are not just recognised in this category
but in almost every category here are
the nominees for Best Foreign Language
Film from Lebanon Capernaum directed by
Nadine labaki from Poland cold war
directed by pavel public hostel from
germany never look away
directed by florian henckel von
donnersmarck food from mexico little man
directed by Alfonso
from Japan shoplifters directed by
little puzzle for Diego and the Oscar
goes to
[Applause]
this is the ninth movie from Mexico to
be nominated and the first to win the
Oscar for foreign language film
[Applause]
am I going to get subtitled well the
well thank you yeah Lisa Thank You
marina Thank You Gabriela and Nico
or the cast and crew I grew up watching
foreign language films and learning so
much from them and being inspired films
like the Citizen Kane just Rashomon The
Godfather I'm breathless when asked
about in the wall book a about the new
wave shall a cloche Herald said there
are no waves there's only the ocean and
I think that the nominees tonight
have proven that we are part of the same
ocean a I want to thank my family Mexico
for be the beach where these film comes
from and also to all mo boo and who
knows to be the Korin that pushes my
drift
thank you so much
[Applause]